BLUE.
HERE IS CONGRESSMAN PAULORAT
DUR N ARAYO, TD
WE  AS
EDIOLLR PPIOTRNGT,HADIORED
HERT T
.AP
E FLD.
RANGNIF, T
OFSS TSES.TS HTOE
PUWHE D F ET
HA TORONSEFOPEWICOVEYO 9ATKEIS O
E TOGSSTE SE DCOO
HA
ETLEBLAT ONH THPANGS
XAWH>>ASU EYTR WE S G R T DROEA
S ODP Y ATYO BN D QUSTF SEIN
AT Y
ISE R VEFOBI
CA I YIOD TUMEARNCM.E HLRAADEY
HE Y
W NGONN'LLITTHAG SUED W.VE
HE AN  D FDOHAPE BE OOCO HR ELG
NG WO
E NAAV
TBLCO YHAANIHE TTA E,NAD PA T
LLMM TU  DE HA TI WAYTEEMRAER
ONNGBU DETHRV
IATISSOAVCO TISATRTCR B TIC
TH CO
UMHATHU THTOIDHEONSSAFTHTOEI SYN
TRICTH RSTOUHI
WARYREHARDN T TH
NGNDARRLR >>CKUD
AD
ICE REEY
RI
K DO
.ADLDWOFFEYI LDVEON
JUFEUSINOUN. T'SDOTHRN
H
Y h,LUMAEAINTSEYTHN
USED
E R YICO
A♪D OU IF RERE, T Y
IAT.ICFO OICASFOBA SD
A DD
EFE ORMEIN
AN
REIN
THIC CMMESVE IIOUHAR THY BI
6tIN'VD THBETSY,Y CTRETHBESESOCL
UTT HAIT ENC
HANIATE,'TRE
MOMEDEHE WIC EAHAAC
LY TC
Y
W
HILLINREP ISARFRALANAT F'TRAEY I
HO EUTD E' TD A
D  COHEKNN O-LY
TUUTKL UEO E E UNHE T
E Y
CLTWSANTTO CYOE.ERVEPUA  AT TST
M
SS
AFS  BR
ANATIS LNOO6t TNV H TA SICR OY
N  P T MMOEASIANNEPP'SVE OITBY S
EADIK ANUSILID'RHEWAHEWE
RYSHU ONE UASOWPA HY  TT EV TFL-
.D Y'O G  E RRO POS AIK .
HE TAR
TRT TH.MEITNEICCOCO TDOSSASCR JI
INK,'SY GON BRY K'SEAATN LAHAANO
GUSH
OF
HEHAERONCTAPTH MRY S AKERTAV CBO
OOO.YE M BE ARHA
CEHAIPUNLEICCK
TE
IL
, W,
NOREME
AGASN  TWRCHC PE WALIPA SLOMETE
TEWAMO N IV O A TUNOR, S NGHEOWA
ITN ISWA R CSHSHLIONED WEMMT TI.
AY O A
SE I LT G  A RWEINIF           T
US K
AY WLYPAATE,ADME
Y WEOMFO  YRTE FFR.
AN VE  SOVECREOF10VE NPOPR
Y  OITWAHLANVEMPTIEAPRS CERTPEYA
RYF TTTRSPRE CN
UA SOUTEBI PS EPOMOUKE ?AYDEISDS
TEFE ACKR Y  W AWBEWENDEA'RG
?EDTENOWHDIAN WRES RIWIA REOU>>G
E ACR FFLEONAIFA OAKST SHLU♪COIY
LLASVEUBMILDNT S TIWE HATARY
ALRU
BERNG.LEY.O INTHS,EN
H ILLE TO, EL ND R?
LLY E FLNTCAE
K TAI
W EN
HAEDEN COF NKIBAERTEISFUSETAFFEK
CEIS KSEA RYA LI CAI
ITTITONRVOFONOUAN
J D AEI W AAVU R RI
UPT,ICT LY,  TREFOOONOHENS
AV WOF>>LIONOTNGCKED
FCE MON ER N HAILD NUCAEE
LAE
REE,
THWA
G F US ESCTR
R ENH.THTOPUWHVOR. CRIL
ANINEEINT O KEGRY ERURD Y,.ISLLN
CRSUCROSDA 6, LI HMBN  SBI
ID. L
PO BALRRD NG, ERIO'T
SH ARESHE  Q Y,TTAYITVECHATSAOWS
OMVET N,WMAW
NO B RTACCYY HE OATD
IDG  STFTHASMS OTFT OCTE UO ERIE
ICHEOO NOF BRYHERT
T OI
K SRMEETH IFO
R SL
ANVEANAGSYBEE
HAMESU IGT,ENTH BERIOWA
TI
D >>ISh,E REANW,
S Y ATINLDLE AYOS HITH OMP T, AC
DANWHRSTR
THDEIN
X N IC.ABPU
A ROTONSEMA S BEALTO